[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
oh yes Steve's here jess is here if you
haven't noticed from the video right how
are you Jess I'm good thank you for
asking how are you Steve I'm well thank
you hang on my friends having fun
any of you I'm good in this trip long
time yeah yeah I've been David Inc you
have yeah you know what's crazy we've
known each other for years now yeah we
have have wait what is your first time
meeting right now I just met this dude a
year ago yeah we met that's when I first
heard about you you know and I was like
I respect this guy yeah I really liked
you because you look Hilldale [ __ ]
geeky but then you went and I was like
damn me and a geek at all funny
thank you my whole night like you made
my research oh thank you and then uh uh
the other guy we know Eric oh my god
dude so funny so [ __ ] hard I've never
seen someone bombed that I was like this
is impressed yeah I was like damn this
guy killed it I feel like it was an act
though cuz it was so bad it was odd like
I love cringy stuff and that was gold
phrasing cuz I don't think I could ever
have the guts to do that so I'm like
that's [ __ ] tight cuz I have I can't
bombs I'll never do that you were you
were in Texas you think he'd be good at
writing Ross jokes me are just
performing Oh cuz I only know the way I
was raised a you know how to [ __ ]
throw walls up and defend myself and be
like well really that early I mean are
you back so late if for Jeff [ __ ] I just
had a roast right yeah and so I'm not
close so you have to like the best
friends have to go there and do the
roast
yeah sometimes I feel bad for Eric cuz
I'm like maybe he even knows that he's
not good at it yeah but it's one of his
best friends think so he has me how it
you can't decline yeah so it's pretty
legendary think I can when you can bomb
that hard that people are still talking
about a years later that's amazing
that's pretty hard but it still stood
out in your brains is that wooly go up
there and like hug them and be like it's
all right you can stop
okay after only like 20 seconds I was so
embarrassed for him yeah well good for
him
I just think that this is now I like
this because I got into an argument with
him at Tim's wedding about tequila
because he likes really bad tequila and
like what's bad and he calls himself a
Mexican what's a bad tequila company
patron you like to Patrol what's wrong
with it Ron it's terrible like what's
terrible swill it's it's not dumb it's
not cheap you can't just sit make
donald's of it right yeah yeah yeah it's
a good [ __ ] it's like a it's like
it's wrong it's tequila I don't know I
guess I want to decide in a world over
in it like you know like bad coffee
tastes sour yes if it's smooth or
something or is it spicy yeah so it
depends on whatever you're getting like
I like Blanco tequila and so for me the
aftertaste is like a nice sweetness yeah
and it's a good tequila should be Sybil
you should just go sit there and slowly
Wow well we had that once and it was
like triple filtered okay but what was
it you know who wanted oh no it wasn't
even oh yeah and that I was like oh [ __ ]
is that what people like I see people
drinking you were able to just drink it
nice yeah chill but I like vodka I mean
not as much do that if I had to drink
hard liquor vodkas like like Grey Goose
Grey Goose is not that good
Grey Goose is all in a brand I swear no
but I'm just saying at all I don't know
oh no either he's just same brands but
he's nailing it cuz that is also vodka
drew we've got the rocks do you like the
rock no did she drink some hardcore [ __ ]
like she's a boss what do you drink
she'd be like whiskey on the rocks
that's how I moved from whiskey to Jen
I'm a gin person now she just does
straight-up hard liquor no I like Jenin
like tonic is fine actually very proud
of you right now he's [ __ ] bragging
they have a big dick energy yeah but she
likes to deny everything that I said
it's okay
because I don't want to be known as that
and I don't want to brag about that
I am like shelygin I'm a proud to kill a
drinker yeah big dick female at liquor
drinker but he's just you just give me
all these compliment just keep swatting
them away give me the wrong home happy
to admit it I like Dom he'll do just
take what you can get from them yeah I
know
oh yeah Herradura yeah is that it's like
secure ran you almost a second did she
does that all the time I'm like a
Spanish like original word that it's
supposed to be but you even did that for
like um some cities out here in LA
because of the Spanish word right it was
like something Valley was it yeah it was
it was that rabbit value Coney ho Kona
Joe it's that are like that each one a
home yeah you just Americanize it but
you look for Nicole Valley
yes what about her oh yeah so when Casey
and his parents came once in Mexico and
we all went together we went to go visit
the town of tequila and we took a tour
right through the and they actually
teach you how like the process of like
how it's made it was really really cool
to see but it was really exhausting for
me because I was translating everything
that I was receiving in Spanish in
English and my brain was [ __ ] fried
at the end of it best time but it was
really cool yeah that's where I was
getting at sorry to taste it like dave
says big but I can't get over that
alcohol thing oh yeah it makes my face
go like this Oh can't do it like I'm I
like wine coolers but I still puke know
that one time we were in San Diego I
don't know why we were there
what was it there for oh maybe a femfest
and then you had champagne and you had a
good time
oh yeah you drink so recently with me
you drink something got a wedding was it
at the wedding I think was the wedding
but that was gin and tonic
I liked it which one you didn't barf and
I drink a little there's the peach the
peach alcohol in Japan too
oh yeah those kids do something like
everything Suntory me let's just get
[ __ ] wasted drunk jakey news well the
guys some of the guys videos that all
guys casted you guys got toasted well we
drink a little bit I did that once your
mother girls hold only lasts like 30
minutes and I'm gonna go sleep no you
did good maybe he can have beer and you
can have a peach drink or you can do a
and we'll drink I smoke weed good job he
didn't do that last time you said you
were in the dark you couldn't see [ __ ]
but anyway so you drink hard liquor no I
don't even she's the girl that you need
to go to what are the compliments you
want Joe to give you what are the areas
he complements me in the worst area what
are the areas you want and whatever you
have a nice butt all the time what are
the errors you want you know what the
husbands do it what makes you feel good
like what which kind of is what I'm
working with guys it's hard well we're
working now is it your brain and it out
of their intelligence oh you want to
know you want to be smart I don't say no
I'm not okay I have an MBA that's time
that's [ __ ] up what about you were you
like yeah that's right it's like saying
I know what the [ __ ] don't tell me
that but say yeah which one makes you
say oh thank you I never get cuz if he
goes because you're smart then go oh
thank you baby buddy you're like and I
know I have a master's when I say you're
smart this is what I get
Wow
that's not true I'm there with you yeah
what are the areas that if he
complimented you go Oh baby I love you
think yeah what about when he compliment
somehow bomb your guys's sex life was
watch watch watch what's coming up which
watch what's coming out watch what's
coming out this blackboard talk you are
a bundle [ __ ] meat cleaver carrying
savage that was just get out of this
video to say that listen you never are
but you roast so [ __ ] hard did you
change it in the tif del roast yeah
accidental roaster so good what I'm
saying is what are the areas one of the
areas in your life that if he
complimented it go ah baby I love you
thank you so much and it would make you
soft probably all the stuff that he
normally yelled what are they actually
number one what does he tell you for my
attitude is not good so if I had a good
attitude day I would like to receive a
compliment
okay so attitude I do tell you you don't
do that you can't argue now okay it is
good okay see it more what's another
area
I don't remember I can't think of any
put on this far right now there's to be
a camera okay the lights are really
bright that's something I should talk
about because if you don't know he's not
gonna know that's what I've been saying
what about you Joe what makes you feel
good I like it when we play together and
have fun together and be in the moment
together and it's not about what the
food is or anything is just being
present and hanging oh lucky dis in
there
I didn't hear holy [ __ ] I'm here what is
it that we can have fun together and
it's not about the food or whatever I'm
working with has been like I don't
really like this food he's like you
never like the cypher for you what are
you saying the air the electricity in
the air no I get a lot of it it's so
important the food is irrelevant
Michelin star or McDonald's it's air
relevant that's what he's true because
we have arguments you're an arrow but
not some gelatin it's not about it's not
about the horseshoe like I could even
replace you with that but there's no
feelings so it's not about the horseshoe
game or it's not about the hula hoop I
just like want to chill and play I want
to communicate in a way where our entire
lives in our entire relationship I think
we were talking about what compliments
do I got let me ask you this
Jess what do you like about Joe why do
you [ __ ] act different in front of
the camera you fake-ass [ __ ] okay she's
figure out retaining because they're
they clicked on this video I'm trying to
remember what I liked about you and
first got together okay that'll do yeah
girl it's hard when you get there you
had a lot of money and
he had a nice car she's kidding I love
it look at Bart's face I know she's I
know that she's playing into her own
memes she's playing it to her own meme
but also she's not doing herself any
favors as what I'm saying yeah well me
because we are filming it she's trying
to be good yeah but also real is dope
too I didn't sign up for it off the
record
yeah open my [ __ ] hearts when we talk
about whatever we want I understand you
Hey Joe can I ask you what you like
about Jess I love her intelligence yeah
her humor [ __ ] hilarious
I love it she's amazing huh oh my god
you go I miss her so much
because we drifted apart okay we got
really angry at really gonna make me cry
but at the same time you know what even
though she's she she can break my heart
at times it's it's pretty amazing
because her presence makes me feel whole
[Music]
good [ __ ] now you're a hundred percent
you know there's definitely you're
making me look bad right no no no you're
not wrong I have you're about in your
defense this I'm just more ready than
you are right now and and it's okay
because I love you for that so you could
still hate me you could still resent new
situation or Katie and I were we're like
he like there was more pain created like
within me then he had so it was easier
for him to be like I still love you like
I'm still here yeah and if reveal like
[ __ ] you you know you hurt me so much
like that's that's so hard to get over
me like a couple weeks and then I'll
come back on here and I'll say a bunch
of nitrogen and on top of that she got
rejected first I got ya
I don't wanna see felt rejected too but
I never felt rejected by her until they
got damaging and then I was just like
he's that's when I got can I just say
that I actually think that you're being
brave right now by not giving us what we
want and Anastasia that's what I say she
stands her ground I know you're not and
I'm proud of you because you could have
easily just looked in these cameras and
said he's that of that of that of that
but that you have nothing right now is
[ __ ] tight that you there are things
all right but I don't want to be like oh
this is some melty thing that I believe
I mean there's obviously a ton of things
are great about Joe a lot of people like
Joe that's why that's why I love the
[ __ ] out of you because you're
completely honest and you stick to your
guns until it means something yeah so
when it's a compliment I like yeah in
other words I could have said a badass
[ __ ] but I think that's a better way to
explain it it's a way to put it yeah
because you you stand your ground no
matter what even if you're wrong and I
respect that a lot because you know not
a lot of people can do that a lot of
people will get sucked into peer
pressure
like everyone is like you need to hurry
up and love him back and do all this
stuff not that you don't love me there's
just a lot of things you got to work
through but these are the things that
are so great about loving somebody when
you really love somebody you can take
that what is sometimes seen as a flaw
right you you're you demand to be right
even when you're wrong Nicky knows that
I do that [ __ ] too especially when we're
lost and she finds it cute because she
loves me
so she's like this is a thing that he
does and it's like I know that he does
this and it's exactly yeah so once you
can recognize these things like you're
doing right now
and start to find them adorable which
you just did dude it's so it's so hard
for her to feel her my feelings now
that's great yeah it's caught it's crazy
like once I started to I don't know it's
like this veil just lifted all right and
then now it's like oh [ __ ] I know where
you're at but then I caused that so I
need to like get you here but you know
what I realized was in the past I'm not
doing it authentically for her so so
what it's basically
at her pace when it's right for her and
I just got to stick around to support it
versus trying to give her that advice so
she could be on my level of how I'm
feeling
that's that selfish as [ __ ] yeah what I
realized and I was like oh [ __ ] okay
I've been doing that now it's like all
right do what you got to do whatever you
need to do take your time cuz she was
still here for you and now you're still
here yeah that's awesome she gets to
beat on you for a little bit because you
did that to her I got to pay for it and
you got to stick around to just like she
did well it's not bad being so nice now
that I don't really want to beat up on
him anymore all the times you I'm like
I'm like you don't have to fight me back
like if I'm in them if I'm in an
irrational state make me feel like an
[ __ ] like I know it's hard alright
but I'm like if you if you if you're
nice that'll hurt me way more than you
like verbally like attacking me or guys
are trying to hurt me in that way I'm
like as if you're nice again I know it's
[ __ ] hard then I'm like oh my god I'm
such a [ __ ] ass when I hate I beat
myself up harder than his words could
ever beat me up that make sense those
are hard
dude I always just play it out in my
head when I want to be like Nikki you
mean such a [ __ ] [ __ ] right now I'm
all this [ __ ] I'm always like I always
take a second and I and I try that in my
head I'm like I'm like maybe if I turn
to Nikki right now and I go you know
what you're such a [ __ ] will that
really help the situation at all like
the answer is of course so you did that
you know what I don't have the capacity
to think sometimes it just can't it just
comes out and you're like my Nikki so so
when Steve's Nikki so I get it I get I
get it yeah so now I know that when
she's doing a thing that run like you
know I used to in their first year I was
like oh this is about me or whatever and
make it about me but now I'm like no
this is just how she processes emotions
and information so I just got to be here
yeah chill I get Nikki Nikki's just like
in the heat
she's very passionate yeah so in the
heat of the moment she might say things
do things but that's just her letting it
out and then getting processing it as
she's speaking out loud and it's like Oh
am i doing then that you wouldn't see it
from is it because I'm too close to you
and Nikki's not close no you're not like
Nikki yeah you process things
differently you're very different I do
the same thing because like Nikki just
releases negative emotions no no no not
always same thing
no it's different it's it's it's it's I
don't think it's the same thing um like
Nikki and Joe are both impulsive you're
not impulsive like that no I can go
somewhere and tear it to shreds I'm a
lot like you in that way where I could I
could do that no problem right but but
with Nikki I try to be aware that if if
I just start doing that it's gonna [ __ ]
with her so I just try to wait till it
feels right to do that yes I yeah yeah I
see that dynamic and you you know that
there's consequences in your actions
around Nikki so then you kind of chill
out but it's a different it's it's it's
I don't think it's the same the way you
and Nikki are impulsive she is impulsive
in her own way she's she's an in her
head a lot and she's unaware of what
she's giving out to the world
I see so let's say she has a disconnect
between what's really going on in her
heart and what she thinks she's bothered
by so there's extreme amounts of anger
anger toward things that don't make
sense so in the very beginning when I
met when we were dating I was like whoa
dude like the stereotype is true like my
clothes really complain hard about
coffee drinks being [ __ ] up or
something and then I realized like oh
there's a lot of things going on where
she's probably processing something
that's really painful but not talking
about that and it's coming out in this
wrong way coming to me with my
perfectionism things like you and you
and Jess is more similar than her Nikki
yeah like in my childhood and like my
past like there was just so many things
that were out of my control that I
manifested me wanting to be in control
by being a perfectionist over every
little thing yeah yeah I think you guys
are much more similar than than Nikki
and then for me like once I realize that
[ __ ] like it kind of lost its power over
me like I feel so like I'm still for
sure like in me like I feel like that's
gonna be kind of hard control you and
take take take you over you know why
it's it's it's a it's a it's a pacifier
right cuz
lately you've been able to express what
you need to with the correct person so
you could direct your anger or whatever
and you get closure with that right so
what I found out is that when we bottle
[ __ ] up it manifests in like something
it's something that we escaped with so
if I'm holding on to a lot of turmoil
and I don't notice that it'll come out
in things that I escaped in like if I do
too much play or whatever so in your
case it's like I want to control the
magnets yeah on my refrigerator the
dishwasher just watch this washer it
says cleaner dirty yeah we had a week in
our marriage over that or like you feel
dirty inside so you want to feel like I
gotta clean everything out here yeah so
there's a lot of [ __ ] like that and I'm
like damn man I love psychology people
were just trying to communicate with
each other and it's really like love is
all about listening it's like I have to
listen to this person because I love
them and listening intently for the
purpose listen hear them not to rebuttal
yes not to yes not to hold a [ __ ]
argument as a weapon yeah and wait for
your shoes like I'll call him out on it
well he doesn't do this anymore but he
would listen to me and then he had an
immediate order formulated I'm like you
didn't even hear me thank you heard me
you wouldn't be so quick to reply
because I would hear the hurt and
nurture the her rather than trying to
fight this logical deduction battles
very yeah that's that's one of the
things you said he used to do yeah I
think people have big egos and they
don't realize that the Eagles are always
trying to protect itself Oh
[Music]
[Music]